Would you like to make some
money with your Android app?
But things are complicated.
[INAUDIBLE] with credit card
and billing systems, right?
Hi.
I'm Neto Marin, and I'm
here to help you understand
how to use and write
In-app billing in your app,
to make it easier for
you to earn some money.
There are several ways
to monetize your app.
You could show
advertisements with AdMob,
offer upgrades from
a Freemium version
or pay for premium features,
sell virtual goods.
Also, you could use subscription
model for app or service.
And for some of
these methods, you
can use In-app Billing
to collect your money.
In-app Billing is
a service hosted
on Google Play that lets you
charge for additional content
and upgrades in your app.
When you integrate In-app
Billing with your app,
you can use the API to request
product details from Google
Play, issue orders
for In-app products,
and quickly retrieve
shipping information,
based on a user's
purchase history.
For users, Google
Play provides a check
out interface that makes user
interactions with the In-app
Billing service
intuitive and seamless.
The In-app Billing
API does involve
some rules and best practices.
You can use In-app Billing
only to sell digital products.
For example, we're
talking products
including coins, extra
lives, special items,
or additional levels.
App features or content
such as ad-free version,
or features that are not
available in the free version.
Subscription services
such as streaming media,
[INAUDIBLE] video, or
other media service.
But there are
other products that
are not allowed
by In-app Billing,
like retail merchandise
such as groceries, clothing,
housewares, and electronics.
Service fees, including tax
and transportation services,
cleaning, food
delivery, and others.
One time membership
fees or recurring dues,
including gym
memberships, [INAUDIBLE],
or other fiscal products.
One-time payments,
including peer
to peer payments, online
auctions, and donations.
Or electronic bill payments,
including credit card bills,
[INAUDIBLE] and cable or
telecommunication services.
For more details
about this policy,
check out our support page.
The first step of
implementing In-app billing
is to define your products,
using the Google Play Developer
Console, including product
type, SKU, price, and so on.
The Version 3 API supports
manged In-app products
and subscriptions.
Let's see more details
about each type.
Managed In-app
products are items
that are tracked and
managed by Google Play.
It means that Google
Play stores the purchase
information for each item.
This information is persistent
all Google Play services,
even if the user
uninstall an application,
or if they change device.
And with the Version 3 API,
you can consume managed items,
and they could be
purchased multiple times.
This is useful if you're
implementing a game,
for example, where the user
can buy currency, food,
or magical potions,
and [INAUDIBLE]
you are responsible for
provisioning these In-app
products to the users.
For In-app products that
can only be purchased once,
it's not necessary to
implement consumption,
because after
purchase, these items
will be permanently associated
to the users Google Account,
like a premium upgrade
or a level pack.
The other type of product
offered for In-app billing
is subscription.
Subscriptions allow you to sell
content, services, or features
on a recurring schedule,
with automated billing.
When users purchase
subscription in your app,
Google Play handles
all check out details,
so you never have to process
any financial transactions.
Subscriptions can be offered
for recurring billing,
at your choice of intervals.
Weekly, monthly, 3 month, six
month, annually, and seasonal.
And you can even set
up a free trial period
that lets users try
your subscription
content before buying it.
Google Play supports free trials
for all subscription types,
including seasonal
subscriptions.
And promotions are a great
way to attract new users,
or engage with users that may
have been away for a while.
With Version 3, you
can use In-app billing
to create and manage
promo codes for products.
As we can see, In-app
Billing offers many benefits
for you and your users.
In the next video,
we'll go hands on,
and I will show you how to
define products on Google Play
Developer Console, implement the
purchase flow, and much more.
If you want to start
exploring on your own,
check out the documentation and
our guide about In-app Billing
API.
Thanks for watching, and
see you in the next video.
Bye.